bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour la suite des
débats dans l'hémicycle sur le projet de
loi transition énergétique et croissance
verte portée par la ministre de
l'écologie ségolène royal c'est l'un des
projets de loi phare de ce début d'année
en projet de loi ambitieux mais aussi
très conséquent puisqu'il n'y a plus de
900 amendements et il fallait s'y
attendre les sénateurs ont pris un peu
de retard sur le calendrier
ils en sont toujours au grand titre 2
sur l'isolation des bâtiments ils
reprennent à l'article 3 pour lever les
freins à l'isolation des bâtiments et
plus particulièrement à un amendement
qui porte sur les dérogations pour les
monuments historiques le climat vous
allez le voir est plutôt respectueux je
vous laisse découvrir ça dans
l'hémicycle la séance est reprise
chers collègues nous reprenons la suite
de la discussion du projet de loi adopté
par l'assemblée nationale après
engagement de la procédure accélérée
relatifs à la transition énergétique
pour la croissance verte dans la
discussion des articles
nous en sommes au vote sur l'amendement
numéro 720 au sein de l'article 3 y at
il des explications de vote
je n'en vois pas je mets donc aux voix
l'amendement 720 avec deux avis
défavorables
il est retiré parfait donc j'en viens à
l'amendement 502 que je mets aux voix
avec deux avis favorables
pas d'explications de vote qui est pour
et qui est contre l'amendement est
adopté
nous en venons à l'amendement 485
rectifié je le mets aux voix avec deux
avis défavorables
alors allez-y leurs collègues du madame
blanc des excuses en lui et en
remplaçant soutien de monsieur leleu qui
vous présente ses excuses
là je retire l'amendement 485 rectifier
et par contre je suis à mende le
l'amendement 543 suivant de madame
monnier les deux avaient la même
rédaction sur le fond avec une
différence c'est que monsieur le allez
un petit peu plus loin dans les zones
sur lequel l'accord de mbf étaient
nécessaires en ce qui concerne les parcs
nationaux régionaux et régionaux les pnr
et les zones classées au patrimoine
mondial en vue de trouver un accord
consensuel dans les différents pans de
notre assemblée
je retire la bande nantes dessus de
l'oeil et je suis à mende
l'amendement de madame monnier en
intégrant les zones sur lesquelles notre
pays a pris des engagements
internationaux c'est-à-dire les zones
classées au patrimoine mondial et je
retire donc la partie pmr merci merci
monsieur mouillé donc l'amendement 4 485
rectifier et retiré quelle est la
rédaction exacte de votre
sous-amendement parce que là vous en
avez donné le contenu mais nous avons
besoin de sa rédaction
l'amendement préparer au mieux le
intégrer les éléments suivants dans une
zone inscrite sur la liste du patrimoine
mondial en application de la convention
de l'organisation des nations unies pour
l'éducation la science et la culture du
16 novembre 1972 et dans sa zone tampon
ce sont ses membres de phrases que je
vous demande de rajouter à l'amendement
de madame monnier entendu donc là
viendrait après en application de
l'article l 331 tiré 3 du même code
on aura joué président on rajouterait
dans une zone inscrite sur la liste du
patrimoine mondial en application de la
convention de l'organisation des nations
unies pour l'éducation la science et la
culture du 16 novembre 72 absolument
mais vous ne rajoutez pas et dans la
zone tampon si c'est ce que me suis
permis de vous allez jusqu'à la zone
tampon absolument puisque c'est n'osant
les engagements de nos accords y portent
aussi ce réseau en temps c'est clair
bien c'est clair pour tout le monde
quel est l'avis de la commission sur le
sous-amendement la commission monsieur
président avait demandé aux auteurs qui
était monsieur à l'époque et âme à la
menier de retirer leurs amendements
le vous aviez eu satisfaction en ce sens
que c'est au maire qu'on leur donnait le
pouvoir vous remettiez une contrainte
une contrainte à mon avis il utile je
voudrais vous rassurer madame la
ministre n'avait confirmé aussi
lorsqu'on est dans ces zones dites
protégées
c'est le droit courant qui s'applique
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que dans
ce secteur-là
il peut y avoir des rogations de temps
en temps par exemple si l'architecte des
bâtiments de france autorise le maire
dans certains cas l'architecte des
bâtiments de france ne donnera pas au
maire le point de déranger et donc le
droit courant est suffisant je pense que
savait pas bon d'apporter une contrainte
supplémentaire et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous avais demandé et allah
et à l'autre de bien vouloir retirer vos
amendements
ces cas l avis du gouvernement madame le
ministre vis que le rapporteur bien
alors je la main le sous-amendement et
l'amendement sont maintenus parfait donc
nous en arrivons aux explications de
vote puisque je vais mettre voit le
sous-amendement madame lienemann
soutenir le sous-amendement et
l'amendement de m d'amonier j'entends
bien l'argument de madame la ministre et
de monsieur le rapporteur
sauf que nous n'avons pas la même
lecture de cette réalité selon que quand
on consulte les professionnels sur la
réalité du fait que l'ancienne
législation protectrice ce que nous
expliqué madame la ministre ce matin
s'appliquerait de plein droit sur ces
terrains en lieu et place de ce qui est
proposé
donc nous nous tenons beaucoup à cet
appel politique sur la qualité du
patrimoine et la non remise en cause de
ce patrimoine et nous préférons nous
voter cet amendement comme un amendement
qui montre la volonté du sénat de ne pas
être dans le flou sur le fait qu'on
reste bien avec cette protection
maximale et s'il nous est fait la preuve
pendant les débats à la cmp ou si jamais
il y avait d'autres lectures on
baliserait pour être sûr de ne pas être
redondant mais bon j'ai tellement
d'expérience comme les uns et les autres
d'entre vous sur le fait qu'on nous dise
oui c'est déjà couvert par les textes c
est dans les détails pile poil ça ne
marche pas permettez moi de vous dire
que vu les consultations juridiques
diverses que j'ai autour de moi je
préfère qu'il ya un acte politique du
sénat à l'étape où nous sommes merci pas
d'autres explications de vote donc je
mets aux voix le sous-amendement ainsi
libellé comme gelée indique est à
l'heure qui est pour avec deux avis
défavorables qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté j'en viens
donc à l'amendement maintenant 543 ainsi
sous-amendé qui est pour
ah vous voulez faire une explication de
vote modem plan de toutes mes excuses à
visite
merci beaucoup la commission de la
culture s'est engagé de très longue date
dans la protection du patrimoine d
architecture locale etc et j'en ai été
l'animatrice et acteurs et les parfois
même quand la commission des affaires
économiques s'en prenait aux choix des
architectes des bâtiments de france
néanmoins après avoir bien lu expertise
et ce qui nous est proposé
les écologistes auraient préféré par le
premier amendement que nous avions
présenté revenir au texte de l'assemblée
il a été retiré dans un souci de
recherche de consensus et à l'éclairage
des avis donnés par le rapporteur et par
la commission et par la ministre
nous avons trouvé un consensus qui fait
attention bâti qui fait attention à l'
architecture qui rend le pouvoir à la
sagacité du mais si nous votons
l'amendement qui nous est proposé
aujourd'hui on retire au maire le
pouvoir d'être intelligent et du coup on
va empêcher les choix judicieux au coup
par coup
en conséquence je ne soutiens je ne
voterai pas et les écologistes ne
voteront pas cet amendement et nous
plaidons pour le consensus qui s'est
dessiné entre le banc de la commission
et la ministre
merci pas d'autres oui monsieur vasselle
merci c'est l'intervention de madame
glandage m'amène à intervenir parce que
j'avais cru comprendre d'après les
explications qu'elle avait données
le rapporteur
monsieur poniatowski à monsieur le que
la rédaction qui venait de la commission
permettait de laisser une appréciation
au maire de faire ou de ne pas faire ce
dont je me préoccupe dans le moment
présent avant d'exprimer mon vote
c'est de savoir et là je souhaiterais
que rapporteur plus nous éclairer si en
adoptant cette cet amendement on fait
disparaître la rédaction de la
commission en ne laissant plus au maire
ce pouvoir d'appréciation et en
simplement en ajoutant à l'ensemble des
mesures dérogatoires celles qui
apparaissent dans le temps donc il
m'apparaît important que cette précision
du soin d'apporter de telle manière à ce
que nous ne soyons pas dans l'erreur au
moment où nous allons exprimer notre
vote parce que je comprends tout à fait
la démarche qui est fait par notre
collègue madame meunier l'amendement qui
a été qu'ils aient été défendue j'adhère
à ce souci mais il faudrait pas que dans
le même temps en voulant bien faire on
puisse être privé de se voir
d'appréciation que la commission avait
voulu donner ouais merci monsieur l'un
porteur cher alain vasselle
tu as très bien compris et je remercie
madame blanc d'avoir expliqué dans ce
cas de figure bien précis avec
l'adoption de cet amendement
le maire n'aura plus aucun pouvoir il
comprit de déranger et vous l'avez très
bien expliqué je vous en remercie la
raison pour laquelle l'amendement et ne
pourra donc le rappeler qu'un pouvoir
notamment dans ces zones protégées
or qu'est ce qui se passe dans le droit
actuel dans ses sites protégés parfois
dans certains cas de figure l'architecte
des bâtiments de france dira vous ne
touchez pas et angers dry a raison il
faut que le omer respecte cette décision
parfois l'architecte des bâtiments de
france dira aubert vous pouvez dans tel
cas de figure déranger est autorisée
mais en adoptant cet amendement c'est
fini c'est terminé
on a retiré le pouvoir au maire c'est la
raison pour laquelle je souhaitais que
on adopte et qu'on reste au texte adopté
par la commission des affaires
économiques
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame
monnier si j'ai bien compris ce qu'a dit
madame la ministre elle expliqué qu'en
fait on n'avait pas besoin de faire cet
amendement parce que les zones protégées
étaient déjà pas du pouvoir du maire
donc ça ne change rien c'était plutôt
que notre amendement était redondant en
nous ce qu'on dit bien puisque c'est
redondant
on le maintient quand même pour bien
expliquer que le sénat est conscient des
enjeux patrimoniaux clients c'est bien
ce que madame la ministre a dit elle a
dit vous n'avez pas besoin de le faire
parce que ces zones qui sont protégés de
toute façon seront soumis elle a lu tout
à l'heure aux bâtiments de france pour
qu'ils donnent leur avis donc c'est pas
enlever le pouvoir aux mains parce que
de toute façon
en fait ils ne l'ont pas sur ces
servitudes qui sont le classement en
zppaup ou en site protégé d'amonier
monsieur le scouarnec m'avait demandé la
parole oui je pense que chez président
merci
il est temps de consolider les pouvoirs
du maire avec l'évolution des
intercommunalités ou les communes
perdent un peu de leur pouvoir et je
serais ennuyé que que le pouvoir des
maires soit vraiment en amputer un peu à
suite à notre décision de voter tel ou
tel article dont je je me je pense que
ce qu'a dit monsieur rapporteur est
alain la ministre ne m'a dit qu'il faut
ne pas voter cet amendement pour que les
mères vraiment garde tous ses pouvoirs
merci bon y at il d'autres explications
de vote
je n'en vois pas donc je mets aux voix
l'amendement 543 sous-amendé
précédemment avec deux avis défavorables
qui est pour l'amendement 543
le 10 11 à 12 pieds contre 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 14
il est pas d'objets qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté nous en arrivons à
l'amendement 486 se rectifier même vote
même vote
il n'est pas adopté un amendement 487
monsieur vasselle parce que monsieur le
lieu avait très justement expliqué la
préoccupation qui était la sienne parce
que là on sort du périmètre uniquement
des monuments classés ou inscrits à
l'inventaire ou des zones qui sont
listées par des dispositions
réglementaires ou d'initiatives qui les
identifie parfaitement
nous avons comme l'a expliqué d'ailleurs
gérard longuet des exemples de
patrimoine dans en milieu rural d'une
qualité et même en ville d'ailleurs
d'une grande qualité c'est que tu râles
dont les les façades appartiennent à
notre patrimoine historique et classés
ou non classés mais qui présentent un
intérêt pour ce qui concerne l'histoire
architecturale notre pays il serait
dommage que par une disposition de cette
nature cette partie du patrimoine
puissent être affectées par les travaux
dont il est question dans ce texte de
loi
alors j'ai bien entendu ce qu'a dit
madame le ministre en faisant valoir que
certes on peut imaginer que ce que nous
demandons ce que demandait notre
collègue sur le lieu puisse être retenu
mais en le faisant en dedans comme
référence uniquement les doigts de 48
on ne permettrait pas de réaliser des
travaux d'économie d'énergie sur les
façades des cours intérieures des
immeubles qui elles n'ont pas le même
caractère architectural que celle
surtout en façade donc mon intervention
a juste pour objectif non pas forcément
pour dire il faut
adoptez les yeux fermés donc cet
amendement mais appeler l'attention de
la haute assemblée du gouvernement et du
rapporteur et de la commission
compétente pour dire entre profitons
peut-être alors il n'y a pas de navette
puisque nous sommes dans une lecture
accélérée mais qu'il y ait au minimum
une réflexion conduite entre les deux
assemblées pour trouver une rédaction
qui préviendrait de satisfaire au moins
l'esprit de la demande qui est fait
quitte à ce que ceux ci soient renvoyées
à un décret d'application pour préciser
les conditions d'application
donc c'est une raison pour laquelle moi
je suis assez hésitant quant à rejeter
purement et simplement cet amendement en
l'état et monsieur bonnecarrère vous
avez considéré monsieur le président que
l'amendement 486 qui concernait donc la
barrière des bâtiments réalisés avant 48
et ceux à poster y faisait l'objet du
même vote
il n'y avait pas de difficultés puisque
monsieur le mhave est indiqué qu'il
considérait que son amendement 487 c'est
à dire celui indiquant que la capacité
dérogatoires prévues à l'article l 123 5
2 2 peut s'exercer pour des édifices ou
partie d'édifices construits en
matériaux une professionnelle était son
amendement de repli comme il vient de
vous aiderai indiqué malgré le vote
précédent je me permets d'insister et de
maintenir l' amendement de repli de
monsieur je veux bien qu'on accepte
toutes les dérogations du monde à un
moment donné il faut aussi quand même
qui a des limites et je vous renouvelle
peu si sur des caractéristiques de
bêtises je ne reviens pas sur ce que
nous avons pu dire monsieur longuet
monsieur le ou moi-même dans la
discussion préalable sous l'article 3
mais si on autorise des dérogations qui
dénaturent des façades qui sont
effectivement dans les matériaux
caractéristiques
à un moment donné sans insister sur
l'exemple albigeois monsieur réquier ont
nourri beaucoup d'autres exemples à
travers la france il me semble que là on
met le doigt dans un engrenage qui est
effectivement dangereux pour la
préservation du patrimoine donc je me
permets
en acceptant le vote qui est intervenu
sur le 486 rectifier mais d'insister sur
le 487 rectifié de monsieur le qui
concerne les matériaux traditionnels et
si vous pensez qu'il y à des
améliorations juridiques techniques
apportées
ça pourra tranquillement être le cas
dans le débat en commission mixte
paritaire mais tant que nous n'avons pas
de garanties suffisantes
il serait déraisonnable de retirer cet
amendement de repli et je prie mes
collègues de s'associer à la proposition
de monsieur le
merci monsieur bonnecarrère madame
lienemann oui moi je soutiendrai cet
amendement parce que je dois le dire
franchement je peux être je manque de
rationalité mais je ne comprend pas
exactement qu'est ce qu'il va
s'appliquer quand j'entends d'un côté
notre à porter sur la précédente
amendements et la ministre et je craque
sur bien d'autres sujets comme celui à
soi même cas d'un côté on dit selmer et
de l'autre on dit pas de problème les
codes y'elle machin du de l'urbanisme
qui correspondent à ces terrains
continuent à s'appliquer aussi
continuent à s'appliquer c'est pas le
maire dont moi personnellement j'aime
bien comprendre quand je vote et je
pense que ces sujets sont suffisamment
importants on a suffisamment d'histoire
ou même le collègue maire comme
d'ailleurs parfois les hauts
fonctionnaires ou d'autres
fonctionnaires ont sacrifié une partie
de notre qualité architecturale au motif
qu économiquement que la modernité
cabiddu les je ne sais quoi que
personnellement je pense qu'il faut une
grande précaution
comme il reste qu'un seul amendement sur
ce sujet je le vote très bien
je ne vois plus d'explications de vote
donc je mets au voile amendement 487
rectifier avec deux avis défavorables
qui est pour cet amendement
de tout ce qui est contre 1,6 abstient
l'amendement 487 rectifié est adopté je
mets donc on voit l'article 3 qui est
pour l'article 3 qui est contre qui
s'abstient l'article 3 est adopté nous
en arrivons à un article additionnel
après l'article 3 et c'est l'amendement
643 électrifié madame jouanno vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues il s'agit
d'un amendement très technique qui vise
à lever les difficultés juridiques liés
au surplomb surfent au voisin pour les
îles aux isolation de pignons limite
séparative en gros quand on a un creux
qu'on veut qu'on veut isoler en bâtiment
et qu'on surplombe un autre bâtiment
appartenant à un autre propriétaire
l'objectif de cet amendement est bien
évidemment de faciliter l'isolation par
l'extérieur puisque l'on sait que celle
ci en potentiel d'économie d'énergie de
15% supérieur à l'isolation par
l'intérieur puisque on supprime en
général on évite les ponts thermiques
ici il y à un frein comme je vous le
disais il ya une difficulté juridique a
été noté par notamment par les experts
juridiques du plan de bâtiments et pour
permettre cette isolation par
l'extérieur il faut justement une petite
atteinte au droit de propriété c'est un
droit qui est extrêmement protégé comme
vous le savez on ne peut y porter
atteinte que pour cause d'utilité
publique
l'isolation les économies d'énergie et
l'environnement font partie des des
atteintes possibles au droit de
propriété ça a été reconnu par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme par
conséquent on vous propose par cet
amendement de créer une nouvelle
servitude d'utilité publique très limité
on est sur 50 cm je rappelle alors non
mais juste pour être clair il s'agit
quand vous vous avez deux bâtiments
vous avez un creux entre deux bâtiments
et donc vous voulez isolé par
l'extérieur le bâtiment qui surplombe
l'autre il s'agit d'une d'autoriser une
dérogation sur 50 cm sur le surplomb
voilà grosso modo l'objectif de cet
amendement comme je vous le disais c'est
pas moi qui le rédige et vous l'avez
bien compris puisque je ne suis pas une
spécialiste du droit de l'immobilier
c'est un amendement qui a été rédigé par
nos collègues du plan d'action 6 quel
est l'avis de la commission monsieur
l'emprunteur mais chaque année oui
laeken monsieur à donner à l'avis
défavorable
je voudrais comment attirer votre
attention sur le fait que regard du
droit propriété c'est un vin problème ça
veut dire que si quelqu'un veut isoler
par l'extérieur
comme l'a très bien expliqué notre
qu'avec madame jouanno ça va déborder ça
peut déborder de beaucoup ça peut
déborder de 50 cm et le ou les voisins
ne rompt donc plus rien le droit de dire
si on aborde si on accepte cet
amendement c'est une vraie atteinte au
droit de propriété
alors non mais aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui ça arrive mais on
oblige à ce moment là celui qui veut
faire ces travaux allaient discuter avec
ses voisins il ya la possibilité de
négocier il ya parfois parfois le
problème n'est pas si brutale que ça
comme ce sont des immeubles qui ne se
touchent pas et c'est un débordement sur
un jardin simplement c'est pas
dramatique et en général il ya des
accords de voisinage quand ce sont deux
propriétés quasiment qui se touche avec
le débordement au dessus de l'immeuble
voisin c'est un vrai problème dans ce
cas là c'est là je dirais on va de les
deux vont devant la justice mais il est
très rare qu effectivement que l'on
donne le droit à celui qui veut faire
ces travaux de déborder au dessus du
voisin enfin tous les cas c'est la
raison pour laquelle en commission nous
avons donné un avis défavorable et cher
collègue m'a demandé de le retrait de
cet amendement est donc si c'est par
tresser défavorable merci monsieur long
un poteau recueille l'avis du
gouvernement madame mise même avis que
le rapporteur et préfère d arrangement
amiable entre entre voisins car en effet
il faudrait préciser là
la taille au moins dû des morts si on
s'engager dans cette direction là et
donc en effet face en plus à l'aléa de
cette dimension je pense pas qu'ils
ovation mesure 50 cm cela dit je pense
que ces quelques centimètres mais ça
peut aussi relever laden accords
amiables aux dispositions
conventionnelles au niveau d'un
territoire pour ne pas empêcher
effectivement les travaux d'isolation
sans porter atteinte à la limite de
propriété
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président mais tard merci monsieur le
président terrorisme et chérèque je
trouve que c'est un amendement qui est
qui est dangereux dangereux oui parce
que ça porte atteinte à des dispositions
monsieur dantec on peut avoir le droit
de s'exprimer de ne pas être d'accord
avec vous on sait bien que vous faites
tout ce que vous voulez en matière
d'écologie mais vous allez nous laisser
nous exprimer je dis bien que cet
amendement il est dangereux il ya des
règles du code civil qui ont un sens qui
ont un sens et là sous le sepa n'a
d'ailleurs un amendement de civilistes
ça se voit c'est un amendement très
administratif très technique chère
collègue sans aucun doute mais là vous
vous permet trier à un propriétaire qui
veut isoler par l'extérieur dans tous
les cas de figure un d'aller coller sa
protection extérieure en surplombant 2,5
de 50 cm dans les conditions qui sont
effectivement une atteinte général aux
droits de propriété dans ces cas là or
et en plus il faut aller jusqu'au bout
il est indiqué que s'il y a des
contestations
ce qui est quand même assez original et
bien les contestations elles sont
soumises obligatoirement à une médiation
préalable à peine d'irrecevabilité à une
d'une demande contentieuses et vous
obligé le président du tribunal de
grande instance statuant en référé a
désigné un médiateur s'est passé quand
même pas rien parce que si on fait ça
dans ce cas là pour déborder de 50 cm
mais il va falloir le généraliser dans
bien d'autres cas on peut pas à la fois
touché de cette manière aux principes du
code civil et on ne peut pas en plus
touchées à les principes de procédure
civile qui me paraissent quand même
relativement important à moins de
modifier tout
donc je crois que ce n'est pas une bonne
chose et je rappelle je rappelle qu'il
existe ce qu'on appelle la servitude de
tour d'échelle quand il ya quelqu'un qui
bloquent pas pour le surplomb mais en
tout cas pour aller faire les travaux
on peut obtenir par la servitude du tour
d'échelle le fait d'y aller donc il faut
faire attention à des choses qui
paraissent extrêmement mesure est simple
mais qui en fait ne le sont pas du tout
et qui sont une porte ouverte à la
multiplication de véritables contentieux
merci monsieur lézard
madame jouanno monsieur le président je
vais retirer cet amendement
mais je veux vraiment soulever le
problème c'est un point qui m'a été
présenté par les experts du plan
bâtiment qui est soulevée par eux mêmes
comme une des freins des freins à
l'isolation par l'extérieur puisque on
peut le faire si on est sûr si on porte
atteinte au domaine public on peut pas
le faire effectivement sur le domaine
privé
donc il faudra sans doute que vos
services se penche sur le sujet et y
apporte des réponses concrètes
merci l'amendement est maintenu à il a
retiré
parfait donc nous en arrivons à
l'article 4 et monsieur mouillé m'a
demandé la parole oui monsieur le
président madame ministre mes chers
collègues alors quelques mots pour
aborder l'article iv notamment au nom de
la délégation aux collectivités
territoriales l'article 4 traite des
performances énergétiques et
environnementales des nouvelles
constructions dans le texte initial du
projet de loi cet article était centrée
sur trois dispositifs d'une part la
possibilité pour le règlement du pnud
d'imposer aux constructions de respecter
des performances énergétiques et
environnementales renforcées et une
production minimale d'énergie
renouvelable d'autre part l'obligation
imposée aux nouvelles constructions sous
maîtrise d'ouvragé de l'état de ses
établissements des collectivités de
faire preuve d'exemplarité énergétique
et d'être si possible à énergie positive
enfin la possibilité d'appliquer le
bonus de constructibilité aux
constructions satisfaisant des critères
de performance environnementale
l'assemblée nationale a effectué un
certain nombre d'ajouts tel celui qui
prévoit que les collectivités
territoriales pourront bonifié bonifier
leur aide pour les bâtiments à énergie
positive ou faisant preuve d'
exemplarité environnementale la somme
national a aussi apporté quelques
précisions c'est ainsi que la
disposition du règlement du p lus
susceptible d'imposer une production
minimale d'énergie renouvelable pourra
être mise en oeuvre je cite le cas
échéant en fonction des caractéristiques
du projet et de la consommation des
sites concernés ce qui est très apprécié
au niveau juridique le texte de la
commission n'apporte pas de précisions
supplémentaires et rationalisent
principalement l'article clac se
présente ainsi aujourd'hui comme une
honnête tentative d'introduire la
préoccupation de la performance
énergétique et environnementale dans
l'acte de construire que cela passe par
le droit des sols ou par le devoir de
l'exemplarité ou encore par les
incitations financières ou enfin par la
sensibilisation des utilisateurs des
bâtiments nouvellement construit tout
cela est incontestablement utile car la
performance énergétique et
environnementale est un élément
essentiel de la transition de brut du
projet de loi
cependant on perçoit bien au simple
énoncé des dispositions de l'article 4
le degré fléchissant de normativité de
ce texte là nous abordons la
problématique de la complexité car ce
qui est insuffisamment normatif dans un
texte législatif
créée à la fois des résidences et un
vide la délégation a reçu mission de se
demander si ce vide ne risque pas d'être
comblé au détriment des finances ou de
la souplesse de gestion des
collectivités ou de leur liberté
d'administration de ce point de vue la
délégation s'est intéressé à la
disposition de l'article 4 qui d'une
part pose le principe que toute nouvelle
construction réalisée sous maîtrise
d'ouvragé de l'état et de ses
établissements publics doivent faire
preuve d'exemplarité et qui d'autre pas
prévoit que la même construction doit
chaque fois que cela est possible et
énergie positive
ces dispositions sont pour nous
comminatoire en sait qu'elle dispose sur
le ton du commandement que toutes les
nouvelles constructions sous maîtrise
d'ouvragé publique font preuve
d'exemplarité
elle est incantatoire ans que le
commandement des intérêts dans aucun
code
il s'agit d'une disposition pour ainsi
dire hors sol mal intérêt à
l'ordonnancement juridique la seconde
obligation c'est qu'ils imposent
d'opposition nouvelle d'être à énergie
positive ou à haute performance
environnementale sont tout aussi
incantatoire dans la mesure où elle
s'appliquera chaque fois que possible
mais qui peut déterminer le sens de ce
chaque fois que possible le pouvoir
réglementaire
le juge on ne sait de plus il faudra
déterminer ce que c'est que
l'exemplarité énergétique et
environnementale là point de vue
juridique
est ce que veut dire à haute performance
environnementale en en vo nous
aujourd'hui la connaissance au moment de
voter la loi pas véritablement et ce en
fonction de cette analyse et de ses
inquiétudes
sans remettre en cause le fond de la loi
que les rapporteurs de la délégation ont
déposé un amendement destiné à minimiser
les risques financiers et juridiques
je remercie si monsieur mouillé
l'amendement 60,18 n'est pas défendu et
nous en arrivons à six amendements en
discussion commune en commençant par le
202 rectifié terme ce point trop vous
avez la parole l'écouté nous travaillons
en binôme avec mon collègue philippe
roux liés à la délégation des
collectivités territoriales et cet
amendement est un amendement de
simplification et de clarification
puisqu'il pose le principe que toute
nouvelle construction réalisé sous la
maîtrise d'ouvragé de l'état et de ses
établissements publics ou des
collectivités territoriales devra faire
preuve d'exemplarité énergétiques et
environnementales et sera chaque fois
que cela est possible à énergie positive
ou à haute performance environnementale
c'est vrai que c'est une disposition l'a
déjà dit manifestement incantatoire et
qui ne serait de surcroît intégré dans
aucun code pose de lourdes
interrogations juridiques puisque là la
notion d'exemplarité énergétiques et
environnementales ou même les
qualificatifs à énergie positive ou à
haute performance environnementale sont
tout à fait imprécis aussi pourrait-il
conduire une réglementation
d'applications excessivement
contraignantes et coûteuses
ainsi qu'à des risques de contentieux en
outre cette disposition semble sûre sur
père fait at war puisqu'elles existent
d'ores et déjà des objectifs de
performance énergétique incitatifs ou
contraignant pour les bâtiments neufs et
ces derniers doivent tout d'abord
satisfaire aux caractéristiques
énergétiques fixé par la réglementation
thermique 2012 et de plus les
collectivités territoriales qui
souhaiteraient faire preuve
d'exemplarité en matière de
développement durable peuvent tout à
fait s'engager dans une démarche de
labellisation ou une certification sans
cela il faut préférer dmd démarche
souple à l'inscription dans la loi d'un
principe général relevant du droit gazon
comme le rappelait à le conseil d'état
dans son étude annuelle sur le droit
souple il n'est pas souhaitable de voir
se développer dans les instruments de
droit dur que sont les lois et des
décrets les énoncer des énoncés qui
relève aurel et et du droit souple et ne
sont pas normatif
enfin l'étude d'impact est muette quant
aux conséquences financières de cette
obligation d'exemplarité et dans la
mesure où la la rt 2012 renchérit déjà
les coûts de construction de 5% a minima
selon le ministère en charge de
l'écologie un alourdissement des
dépenses d'investissements des
collectivités territoriales est
fortement probable donc en fin de compte
il apparaît que des principes généraux
de ce dispositif pourrait être maintenue
à condition d'en retirer les éléments
potentiellement les plus contraignants
et il s'agirait ainsi de remplacer ce
qui ressemble à une obligation de
résultat par une obligation de moyens
voilà donc les termes de cet amendement
sans enlever le fond du sujet au froid
que c'est un amendement vraiment de de
clarification des simplifications
merci monsieur pointereau vient
discussions maintenant deux amendements
identiques le 29 rectifié mesure où v
merci monsieur le président
ministre sur le rapporteur chers
collègues voilà qu on a des approches et
très technique tout ça et qui peuvent
être un peu différente en fonction d'eux
des éléments d'information qui aurait pu
avoir veut simplement voudrait dire que
les surcoûts constructif des bâtiments à
énergie positive et même le ministre on
en a beaucoup parlé hier
et bien entendu tout ce qui va pouvoir
permettre de développer des locaux à
énergie positive on est tout à fait
favorable sous réserve bien sûr que ça
devienne pas dissuasif financièrement et
donc les coûts de constructif sont
élevés par rapport aux logements basse
consommation en août surcoûts
occasionnés par l'obligation d'achat de
l'énergie produite et non consommés ps
pendant toute la durée du contrat sur la
collectivité nationale
il est proposé de retirer le terme
d'énergie positif et de le remplacer par
hautes performances thermiques et à
moindres émissions de gaz carbonique
ce qui d'une certaine façon aboutit au
résultat que vous souhaitez mais
peut-être est un peu moins contraignant
merci monsieur reuver nous arrivons aux
400 rectifié blâme prima il vient de
défendu brillamment par mon collègue
revers parfait alors le 721 monsieur
dantec
je me sens un peu seul dans le groupe
d'amendements parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'il n'est pas exactement
le même philosophie j'ai l'habitude et
puis il arrive que malgré tout votre la
sagesse collective parce que nous nous
retrouvions l'assemblée nationale
prévoyez donc que les nouvelles
constructions de l'état de ses
établissements publics ou des
collectivités territoriales fasse preuve
d'exemplarité énergétique et
environnementale et là effectivement
ici au sénat la commission a remplacé le
et où en est où hors énergie et
environnement s'est pas exactement la
même chose
et effectivement si on dit qu'on veut
des bâtiments exemplaires il faut qu'il
soit exemplaire sur le plan énergétique
et sur le plan environnemental donc le
et semble logique
j'en profite quand même comme ça je ne
rien faire reviendrait à interviendra
moins pour dire qu' une partie du débat
que nous avons est un débat tout à fait
pertinent sur la définition finalement 2
qu'est ce qu'un bâtiment à énergie
positive et si vous avez été attentifs à
l'ensemble des amendements il y à des
amendements on a dû déposer le même avec
chantal jouanno qui arrive juste
derrière qui propose qu'on le définisse
par décret ce qui réglera le problème
que vous avez exprimées effectivement ça
améliorera la loi alors deux amendements
identiques maintenant le 644 rectifié
biche madame jouanno
merci monsieur le président nous nous
sommes favorables au principe d'aller
vers des bâtiments à énergie positive
c'était d'ailleurs un des engagements du
grenelle je crois que ça a été voté en
grenelle 1
un horizon 2020 simplement il est vrai
que pour les acteurs économiques
il faut absolument qu'on puisse très tôt
définir ce que nous entendons par un
bâtiment à énergie positive afin qu'ils
puissent le plus vite possible s'y
adapter et si et si préparer d'où cette
idée de renvoyer un décret la définition
précise de ce qu'est un bâtiment à
énergie positive
merci madame jouanno le 821 identique au
président monsieur dantec
il est défendu par fait donc je vais
demander à la commission et aux
rapporteurs quel est son avis sur
l'ensemble de ses six amendements
merci monsieur le président alors je le
prends dans le désordre volontairement
pour expliquer du plus sévère ou moins
sévères entre guillemets je commence par
le 721 puisque c'est celui qui veut
revenir à la rédaction de l'assemblée
nationale qui propose donc dans le texte
que toutes les nouvelles constructions
sous maîtrise d'ouvragé publique sont
chaque fois que possible à énergie
positive et à haute performance
environnementale entre guillemets c'est
le plus sévère
nous en commission on a atténué cette
rédaction
puisqu'on a dit il faut que dans ces cas
de figure ce choix ou à l'un ou à
l'autre soit énergie positive soit à
haute performance environnementale
j'en viens maintenant aux amendements
dans l'ordre qu'ils sont présentés le
202 et celui qui entre guillemets s'en
éloigne le plus si je puis dire parce
que en fait même si c'est pas un ali des
acquis entre guillemets très méchant
parce qu'il dit que chaque fois que
possible il faudrait que ce soit énergie
positive à haute performance
environnementale vous l'amendement
pointereau est hostile à ce chaque fois
que possible donc voudrait qu'on le
supprime complètement
autrement dit il n'y a plus d'obligation
pour les bâtiments sous maîtrise
d'ouvragé d'état aux collectivités
territoriales de répondre à ces
contraintes énergie positive
donc c'est celui qui entre guillemets
voudrait d'ailleurs vous auriez pu tout
simplement demandé la suppression de
l'alinéa l'alinéa 3 ce serait revenue je
dirais aux mêmes alors les deux autres
sont atténuées entre deux sont plus
sévères que l'amendement
point trop et donc moins sévère si je
puis dire que non également moins sévère
que point trop et puis c'est vers que
l'amendement adopté en commission bas
dont vous êtes entre deux par rapport à
ces trois amendements ce que je voudrais
vous dire c'est que forcément la
préférence est la rédaction que nous
avions adopté en commission
les deux derniers amendements qui sont
alors pour le coup différents en
commission nous avons pris une décision
de sagesse l'article 4 de la grenade
définir dans les bâtiments à énergie
positive comme des bâtiments dont la
consommation d'énergie primaire est
inférieure à la quantité d'énergie
renouvelable produite dans ses
constructions
bon c'est une définition certes qui
datent 2002 2010
vous soulevez bien le problème en disant
il était logique
cette définition peut évoluer
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que c'est
renvoyé à un décret et donc nous avons
décidé d'adopter une solution de sagesse
en écoutant les explications du
gouvernement
merci monsieur le rapporteur sur le 200
dû rectifier terre le 29 rectifier le
400 rectifier votre avis est défavorable
car vous avez établi une gradation de la
sévérité dans la graduation
aucun des quatre ne me convient nous
avons donné en commission à l'avis
défavorable car nous préférons la
rédaction de celui que nous avons adopté
en commission qui est donc la rédaction
actuelle de l'alinéa 3 le président va
très bien madame la ministre
alors si monsieur le président donc nous
avons là un débat qui est très technique
mais très important parce que c'est vrai
qu'il a d'ailleurs occupé beaucoup de
temps à l'assemblée nationale et ça va
nous permettre d'ailleurs je me
rallierai justement la proposition du
décret pour pouvoir définir ce qu'est un
bâtiment performant disons globalement
puisque on voit bien à la lumière de ce
débat qui va falloir fusionner ces deux
concepts et avoir vraiment qu'une seule
définition pour que les opérateurs
puissent s'y reconnaître pourquoi est ce
que au départ le texte est un cumulatif
derrière les deux parce qu'il ya une
différence entre le bâtiment énergie
positive qui est essentiellement comme
son nom l'indiqué concentrer sur
l'énergie s'était produit au moins
autant voire plus d'énergie qu'il n'en
consomme donc un bâtiment à très grande
efficacité énergétique est d'ailleurs
défini effectivement dans le grenelle et
le bâtiment à haute performance qui est
un concept beaucoup plus large puisqu'il
intègre l'empreinte carbone la gestion
de l'eau la gestion des déchets
l'utilisation des matériaux et c est
pourquoi il y avait cumulatif parce que
vous pouvez être un bâtiment à énergie
positive est une passoire thermique au
sens où si vous installez une centrale
photovoltaïque sur le toit et que vous
revendez l'énergie sur le réseau vous
allez produire plus d'énergie que vous
n'en consommer mais le bâtiment lui peut
être une passoire thermique complète
avec une empreinte carbone importante et
c'est donc c'est bien la combinaison des
deux c'est à dire un bâtiment performant
sur le plan environnemental et à énergie
positive qui constituent la nouvelle
génération des constructions cela dit il
ya effectivement un problème
d'interférence puisque dans le bâtiment
à haute performance environnementale
il ya aussi une partie de performance
énergétique par définition donc c'est
vrai que l'effet cumulatif pose un peu
problème est donc la solution sans doute
c'est
d'accepter le texte de la commission qui
met ou mais de définir assez rapidement
effectivement dans le décret c'est pour
ça que je crois que l'amendement de
madame jouanno est utile c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut maintenant définir assez
rapidement dans le décret d'autant plus
qu'il ya les bonus qui s'attache aux
bâtiments à énergie positive et à haute
performance environnementale
mais ce décret n'est pas très difficile
à faire puisqu'on connaît les critères
et votre commission de lier le décret
assez bien dans son rapport de la haute
performance environnementale et de
l'énergie positive et en combinant les
deux on voit bien puisque les opérateurs
d'ailleurs dû des filières du bâtiment
maintenant on parfaitement défini les
critères puisque quand il quand il offre
des possibilités de construction énergie
positive je vois dans pardon de citer un
exemplaire d'un exemple dans ma région
mais les nouveaux centres de formation
des apprentis
ils sont à énergie positive construction
bois et à haute qualité environnementale
donc ils ont tous les critères que
maintenant les filières bâtiments les
plus performantes maîtrise parfaitement
c'est à dire qu'ils vont du choix des
matériaux jusqu'à l'énergie positive en
passant par le retraitement des déchets
la récupération des eaux de pluie les
toits végétalisés et c'est avec une
palette de choix qui fait que maintenant
les collectivités territoriales peuvent
choisir en toute connaissance de cause
la façon dont elles peuvent construire
des bâtiments qui sont à la fois haute
performance et bien évidemment à énergie
positive mais la vraie énergie positive
celle qui profite au bâtiment lui même
et non pas le surplus d'énergie remise
sur le réseau alors pour n'aurait à un
bâtiment très faiblement efficaces sur
le plan énergétique dont votre avis
défavorable madame la ministre aux
quatre premiers défavorable enfin
suggestion de retrait aux quatre
premiers et avis favorable pour
l'amendement qui prévoit la
clarification par un test qui sera
d'ailleurs très rapidement pris et que
je pourrai sans doute vous communiquer
avant la fin lors le projet avant la fin
de nos débats merci madame le ministre
c'est clair alors je vais mettre aux
voix
l'amendement monsieur pointereau les
vides
je maintiens mon amendement mes chers
collègues je pense qu'à un moment donné
vous êtes que me tous confrontés aux
anneaux élus locaux nous mère quand vous
rentrez chez vous ils ne le disent on a
trop de contraintes dans nos
collectivités à un moment où les
dotations sont en baisse et que vous
allez leur dire quand vous allez rentrer
que vous avez voté une contrainte
supplémentaire dans cet article 4 moi je
me pose la question qu'est ce que vous
allez leur dire que c'est quoi de votre
faute c'est de la faute de ceux qui ont
fait le décret parce que
l'administration on a rajouté où c'est
de la faute de l'europe parce que c'est
une
mais non vous pourrez pas vous en cachez
parce qu'à un moment donné faut prendre
ses responsabilités on peut pas dire
d'un côté ya trop de normes ya trop de
contraintes et cetera et puis que nous
on en rajoute à chaque fois une couche
il faut qu'on arrête les deux
concitoyens en ont ras-le-bol de ces
contraintes à la fois financières
normative et je crois que vous pouvez
pas avoir un double jeu à un moment
donné il faut il faut le dire d'un à nos
élus que comment ils vont faire pour
financer ce qu'on est en train de leur
préparer à savoir qu'il faut être en
énergie positive que il faut que les
bâtiments soient haute performance
énergétique m'enfin à un moment donné il
faut savoir comment on finance tout cela
et moi j'ai pas envie de quand je vais
voir mes élus de leur dire écoutez c'est
ça c'est voté au sénat mois
j'ai vu un certain nombre de mes
collègues qu'il en veut tu es ben moi je
veux pas voter ce genre de show parce
que je sais très bien que nos collègues
dans nos communes notamment les communes
les plus modestes ne pourront pas
s'adapter à cette situation ne pourra
pas financer toutes ces opérations
donc je vous demande des chers collègues
de regarder de plus près les choses et
de voter cet amendement 202 rectifié
parce que il fait partie d'une d'une
avancée que nous voulons avoir au niveau
du sénat c'est à dire qu'on soit au
sénat le moteur de la simplification on
peut plus continuer à rajouter d'abord
on légifère trop je crois que nos
concitoyens nous le disent en permanence
on doit devrait moins légiférer dans cet
hémicycle on devrait davantage
travailler sur la suppression d'un
certain nombre de contraintes de
complexité administrative
je crois que c'est ce qu'attendent nos
électeurs et nos concitoyens nos élus
locaux je crois que c'est une volonté du
président larcher qui a voulu mettre une
mission au sein de la délégation des
collectivités territoriales pour
diminuer la pression normative et bien
écoutez je crois que le moment est venu
et bien d'accompagner cette politique
merci merci monsieur d'allier merci
monsieur le président une madame la
ministre
j'ai cosigné cet amendement alors bien
évidemment je vais le voter
il ya deux il ya deux problèmes dont les
dispositions qui nous sont présentés
effectivement la définition de l'énergie
positive alors on nous renvoie à un
décret bon c'est très bien mais enfin
effectivement on ne saurait on ne sait
pas aujourd'hui à quelle sauce nous
serons mangés
ensuite le chaque fois que c'est
possible moi j'ai du mal à comprendre ce
que ça veut dire puisqu'on parle de
nouvelles constructions réalisées par
une collectivité locale et l'état alors
ça veut dire quoi chaque fois que c'est
possible est ce que c'est une question
de coût puisque techniquement a priori
je vois pas la difficulté si on décide
de le faire mais il ya aussi les
questions de coûts vous nous dites c'est
un surcoût de 5 %
je sais pas si vous avez pour mes
collègues qui sont maires aux présidents
de conseil général sais pas si vous avez
récemment construit des bâtiments en
essayant effectivement d'atteindre les
critères qui vous
fixée moi j'ai essayé madame j'ai essayé
madame la ministre pour une école et je
dois vous dire que je vais pas vous dire
que je m'en mords les doigts
enfin l'expérience a été extrêmement
douloureuse parce qu'entre le prix
annoncé par l'architecte et le résultat
à l'appel d'offres derrière excusez moi
à l'écart était pas de 5%
c'était bien pire que ça à 20% alors
est-ce que c'était uniquement à cause de
cela on peut se poser la question mais
bien évidemment qu'il ya une question de
coûts qui se poser au moment où nos
dotations fondent comme neige au soleil
allez nous imposer cela donc chaque fois
que c'est possible
moi j'ai envie de dire à ce moment là
ont levé le imposé clairement dans la
loi l'obligation puisque je vois pas
comment une collectivité pourrait se
défendre en disant non moi je peux pas
le faire sauf effectivement regard de
critères de critères financiers
voilà alors on est d'accord pour aller
dans cette direction là parce que bien
évidemment il faut faire les économies
d'énergie on s'y retrouve au en
fonctionnement mais au bout de combien
d'années on sait qu'il faut le faire
mais il ya aussi la manière d'écrire la
loi et les conséquences que tout cela
emporte à court terme
et voilà pourquoi moi je me je voterai
cet amendement parce que je pense que ce
que vous nous proposez mais pas
suffisamment précis n'est pas
suffisamment mesuré et encore une fois
je crains que nous ne fassions des
bêtises merci d'un dec
on entend bien que finalement dans dans
cet hémicycle plusieurs voix s'expriment
sur les bancs de la majorité
il ya la volonté du rapporteur que je
salue avec lequel on a quelques vrais
désaccords voulez vous avez pu le noter
il ya quand même la volonté de mettre ce
pays dans le sens d'une vraie rénovation
thermique de ces bâtiments et ça je
crois qu'on ne peut pas lui faire le
procès de ne pas vouloir aller dans ce
sens-là
et puis il y à la position clairement
exprimée par notre collègue point trop
en clair le changement climatique s'est
totalement secondaire et le sénat est à
la pointe mais bien alors attendez
attendez et cher collègue soit c'est
important et on met l'action publique en
cohérence pour atteindre les objectifs
soit c'est demain on rase gratis et
demain on fait des efforts sur le
changement climatique
c'est ça exactement qui se joue là c'est
le sas qui joue
il n'est pas possible de demander aux
français de s'engager dans une dynamique
de qualité du bâti si on a pas d'
exemplarité de la puissance publique
ça ça n'est pas possible ça n'est pas
peu fier de plus de plus de plus on sait
très bien qu'aujourd'hui les surcoûts ne
sont pas si importants et que on va s'y
retrouver en terme de fonctionnement
c'est c'est de la bonne gestion c'est de
la bonne gestion et enfin troisième
point on doit pas vivre exactement au
même endroit
parce que moi je sais que dans dans
l'agglomération nantaise
aujourd'hui on a des citoyens
extrêmement vigilants à la qualité du
bâti
c'est à dire que si on fait un bâtiment
neuf sous puissance publique qui soit
une passoire thermique oms va se faire
allumer et à raison avec nous un parent
par nos concitoyens qui vont nous
trouver irresponsable par rapport aux
grands enjeux énergétiques et
climatiques
donc si si on retire si on retire cet
élément de la loi appartement on est
bien d'accord pour préciser et là je
trouve que le rapporteur et la ministre
une position cohérente en disant on
garde cette position et on prend le
décret d'ailleurs moi je vais retirer
mon amendement pour bien montrer que
l'on cherche effectivement du consensus
j'ai entendu la demande du rapporteur et
de madame la ministre
mais si on enlève ce genre de choses ça
veut dire qu'on dit clairement le sénat
dit clairement la france ne doit pas
faire d'effort sur ses objectifs
climatiques et énergétiques
ça veut dire ça parce que la puissance
publique doit être exemplaire c'est
absolument essentiel et on ne créera pas
de filière avec les artisans avec le
bâtiment et ça serait vraiment encore
une fois choisir la tente plutôt de
l'action merci monsieur zotac monsieur
michael merci monsieur le président moi
je ne voterai pas cet amendement c'est
un amendement de régression que vous
nous proposez les collectivités doivent
être exemplaires
l'émulation doit venir des collectivités
j'ai présidé un conseil général pendant
dix ans j'ai construit plusieurs
bâtiments à énergie positive et mon
successeur
mon successeur
comme vous exprimer je vous écoute ma
chère collègue alors fait son temps mon
successeur se réjouit aujourd'hui du
travail que nous avons accompli
nous avons des économies en matière de
fonctionnement qui sont importantes et
nous n'avons pas eu nous avons eu un
surcoût de bien sûr que j'ai évalué à
l'époque de la construction à 15%
oui je les évalue à 15 % mais les
entreprises locales ont eu accès à ces
marchés elles ont appris d'autres
techniques elles les sommes mises en
oeuvre et aujourd'hui je connais une
entreprise mans deux départements qui
construit clip fait des constructions en
bois qui réalisent des ouvrages
importants qui a créé des emplois parce
qu'elle a commencé à travailler pour le
conseil général sur un bâtiment
exemplaire
alors ne soyons pas si les collectivités
de loin par exemple dans cette affaire
comment nous retrouverons nous nous
avons besoin que les collectivités face
à la démonstration que ça marche et
qu'on peut obtenir des résultats en
matière d'économie d'énergie qui sont
substantielles je crois que nous devons
tous aller dans cette direction
le monde département construit deux
collèges aujourd'hui et ils seront à
énergie positive jeu mais quelle madame
prima vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président pardonnez
moi monsieur michael d'avoir été un peu
rapide dans ma réaction
mais je suis extrêmement choqué par ce
que j'entends extrêmement choqué les
maires sont ils des ânes et bien non les
maires sont responsables les présidents
de conseils généraux sont responsables
vous l'avez dit vous-même ce méga vous
avez construit des collèges à énergie
positive dans les mairies on a des
maisons des associations n'a des écoles
qui se construisent on n'a pas besoin de
loi on n'a pas besoin de loi les maires
sont responsables mais ce chrono
messieurs le dantec on n'a absolument
pas besoin de loi les maires savent
parfaitement quand est ce qu'ils doivent
faire ou quand est ce qu'ils ne peuvent
pas faire des bâtiments à énergie
positive
ils ont en tête les économies qui
peuvent ferries en tête le retour sur
mon moi j'ai des bâtiments à construire
en ce moment j'ai un bâtiment à
construire
il me faut 40 ans de retour sur
investissement pardonnez moi je ne veux
pas qu'on m'oblige à construire un
bâtiment avec à énergie positive
je ne veux pas parce que je n'ai pas de
retour sur investissement je vais faire
un basse consommation je faire tout ce
que je peux pour que le bâtiment soit le
moins consommateur possible mais je vais
faire comme je peux et économiquement
avec les dotations qui me reste les
maires sont responsables les maires
doivent avoir la main et on peut leur
faire confiance pour la transition
énergétique
car que vous l'avez dit ils sont sous
l'oeil de leurs consommateurs et de
leurs électeurs donc il faut leur faire
confiance fait confiance au maire et
arrêtons de les contraindre sans cesse
monsieur de l'âge
merci monsieur le président chers
collègues n'entraîne écrire une loi
n'est pas en train de faire un programme
électoral
chers collègues je vous ai entendu je ne
sais combien de fois nous expliquer que
c'était indigne de faire le procès des
collectivités territoriales et vous
aviez raison et qu'est ce que j'entends
ici aujourd'hui dans cet hémicycle
alors que nous en sommes les
représentants c'est que les
collectivités territoriales ferait
n'importe quoi qu'on ne pourrait pas
leur faire confiance
mais qu'est ce que j'entends ce n'est
pas la réalité du terrain et vous le
savez très bien
et monsieur michael et monsieur michael
vous venez de donner l'exemple de votre
département et j'ai eu la chance de
visiter avec vous ta département très
bien administrer et qui n'avait pas
besoin d'une loi pour savoir ce que vous
aviez à faire et puis je m'inquiète sur
la preuve qu'est ce que c'est que cette
notion de preuves en droit
la preuve je la fais sur l'attention je
la fais sur le résultat